ug mayor professor of statistics and
political science
and
so i'm going to do small and small p now
so i
i
i mean i miss my friend he is also in
hawaii conference he's from yale and i
miss both people uh i mean from el so
there must be something going on at yale
i don't know sample size is equal to
three so we can make an inference but
anyway uh so
uh just going to talk about uh the best
in random force for treatment effect
evaluation just the freud is yours
uh thanks um thanks for the introduction
i apologize for not being there i was in
berkeley as of this last weekend um
because of kovachern my daughter's
school
production got moved to this week
and i had to be here to support her so i
apologize but she's 11 she wouldn't
understand
but i very much wanted to
come and i thought until very recently
i'd be there so i apologize to everyone
and peter in particular
um so today i'm going to talk about uh
this project that grew out of a project
that we did with peter and this is joint
were co-authored by with ben you and few
uh who is a graduate student of ours
so a couple of years ago uh we got uh
peter to write on causal inference uh
and by we i mean ben and another
graduate student of our soren kunzel
and this paper is on
estimating heterogeneous treatment
effects what these are is you know as
the data's growing very large as we get
big n and big p
uh policy makers whether it's in
medicine or political campaigns or it's
on online platforms so on and so forth
they're not interested
so much anymore on what the true effect
is on average
uh they want to know what the treatment
effect is for various subgroups so they
can target the treatment to those
subgroups
um so that's the heterogeneous treatment
effect problem i'm going to give a
little more formalism in a bit
it's a difficult problem um even though
the data has grown large the estimation
problem
is quite difficult to my knowledge
that's the only causal inference paper
peter has written but peter's had a very
large
effect on the causal inference community
uh which is group the cause of influence
community has grown over time and you
know simon's has a this spring uh
several workshops on it
and one of the core work uh workhorse
theoretical models in the cause of
inference literature
is semi-parametric theory and the
parametric efficiency bound
uh and peter with various co-authors and
it's just one citation of many of
peter's work on this
uh has developed that theory and for
reasons we'll see in a few slides in the
case of the average human effect at
least the theory has a naturalness of
application
in
uh causal inference
um
sociologically not just by his written
work in a very personal way peter's had
a large effect
on the causal inference community by
the people he's trained whitney newey
who's a very prominent
econometrician at mit was a visiting
scholar in berkeley in 86
he took peter's class which peter covers
parametric
um
theory in and then he then wrote some
papers and then trained a lot of
students
uh he then mentored jamie robbins uh the
way jamie tells it when he was trying to
convert him to murmur to become a mormon
during this process
the conversion didn't work but he was
taught semi-parametric theory
uh and then jamie um has developed it
for calls on princeton trained many
students as well it's a very personal
way peter's had a large
impact remember talking
about this with peter and peter looked
vaguely bemused and said well it was a
theory of any use was it interesting
um
and so a lot of this talk is going to be
you know peter i talked a lot about how
theoretical statistics interacts with
applied statistics and actual
applications and also peter has an
interest in politics and political
campaigns and this talk is going to
feature on both of those topics
so what's the treatment effect
estimation problem so
this problem and its policy
uh implementation version is what's led
to this work which is developed out of
the work with peter uh out of the work
with peter the technology we had and and
the methods we developed are now in
online platforms you know
part of tech pipelines and a lot of
major firms
a lot of other people are using them and
i keep getting email
uh about it and most of uh problems that
people face are this uh policy planning
problem so you estimate a treatment
effect right which is the effect of a
drug what's an effect of an online ad
what's an effect of a policy to get
people to turn out to vote and then for
the policy maker this becomes a cost
benefit thing there's many many things
they could spend their dollars on
many many things they could do to get
people to turn out to vote there's many
many things they could do to get people
to buy a certain product
and there's a variety of drugs uh or
medical procedures uh one could do and
then you have to trade off costs and
benefits right so there's many many
applications and the health care costs
in case it's often you know not monetary
costs it's often just you know different
drugs at different pluses and minuses in
some cases literally is monetary cost
for years i've done i used to do work
with nice the national super clinical
excellence in the united kingdom which
would literally value a quality adjusted
life here to be about 30 to 50 000
british pounds
uh interventions that give you a greater
return than that they would like to fund
interventions give you a lower return
that they would not like to fund
so when you estimate these treatment
effects you need it to be scaled
properly because you're on the other
side is going to calm costs and you've
got to wait them off
right the thing is any bias now in your
estimates your treatment effect is going
to be really bad right because you can
imagine other cases where all i got to
do is just rank order
of what i think the treatment effects
are and i'm going to take the top five
at which point then bias as long as i've
maintained the correct ranks the bias
isn't going to be a big problem
but in the cases i'm interested in it
and what motivated this work no no the
bias is actually pretty
fatal
um the motivating example and the date
examples i'm going to give here are
going to be election campaign although i
have finance examples there's medical
examples of online tech firms that face
this using the methods to be developed
and others right in the election
campaigns you have uh finite resources
you gotta allocate film overval over val
various policy interventions and you
want to um and you might want to do
various things might want to just
increase turnout you might want to win
an election you might want to do
something else we're going to get into
that
now it turns out that in this world
heterogeneous treatment effects we're
not just estimating effect on average
but on uh but for subgroups even when
you have randomized experiments with
large-scale randomized experiments
obtaining valid confidence intervals has
been quite challenging
even in cases where the estimators
themselves have asymptotic normality
results and so on and so forth the
coverage has been quite bad so one move
is conformal intervals there's a very
nice paper by leewa and emmanuel on
using conformal intervals
with the bias adjustment we can get uh
decent coverage as well although under
clearly stronger assumptions than
conformal intervals but the interval
length is much much uh smaller the
interval length of control intervals is
so large
in ways i'll show that i think it's
going to be pretty challenging for
applied people to use in a sense that
you can have an experiment with the
average treatment effect for example
it's a t-statistic of three
uh so it's very well powered it's a
randomized experiment so it's you know
it's a believable conference interval
and when you do conformal through your
heterogeneous treatment effect estimator
it will cover zero for every subgroup uh
at which point applied people do what
they do and they'll say well i'm not
going to believe that someone tells me
there's an asymptotic normality result
this other thing i'm just gonna uh use
that
um but all of a sudden the key thing
motivating is not the conference
intervals although present results
because they're easier to digest it's
the policy making things which is to say
that conference runs are rarely our
first order problem when you actually
have policy making issues
right one can see this i'll give you an
example of say from kobit we did
large-scale mrna uh randomized trials at
great and massive social cost
uh because we delayed the implementation
of the mra vaccines
uh and every month you delay is
trillions of dollars the global economy
many lives and we got p values that are
credible and design based but the minute
the randomized trial landed all the
policy questions came from well the
antibody response is declining over time
the virus is mutated should you do a
booster
and there was a debate on that the
israelis had one view the fda had
another view the blind administration
leaned on the fda to follow the israeli
view
um the issues here were not really
confidence intervals the issues were all
about what the social welfare tradeoffs
were
um and you know so it's just a highlight
the thing that we actually care about
most the time here isn't very little to
do with the p-value we get although
p-value is something we can you know
guarantee at least in sample at the time
three months later that might not be a
meaningful thing as it wasn't for the
mra vaccines if you ask me now by the
way what's the problem
what is the causal effect of the amr
vaccine for you not to get infected
nobody knows nobody knows it's not a pin
down aspect even though we spent
trillions of dollars
on opportunity class doing those trials
which i'm saying we should have done but
just to highlight what little we know
uh from those trials and practice
all right so in these election campaigns
uh there's very straight ops to be had
right so there's three general
categories of people uh and policy
trade-offs they're all gonna involve
different trade-offs on like say bias
versus variants and other things
you can have a non-partisan group that
just wants to increase turnout
right so this is a very easy thing for
this kind of group if you just ranked
ordered
uh who you should apply treatment to
uh they'll just take it right but then
you have two other types which is you
can have a major donor who doesn't care
about an individual election but just
wants to say flip the senate or flip the
house so this donor doesn't care if you
increase someone's vote percentage from
60 to 70 percent this donor really wants
to move elections that would be
49 to 51
because she's interested in the overall
portfolio not an individual race
uh and wants to like do that under
facebook budget constraint so now bias
is a pretty serious problem for this
person and then the most common case is
a candidate just aims to win but
candidates run scared they don't want to
get 51 percent they won't just maximize
their vote percentage but they care who
is going to be turned out they're not
going to pay to get the opposing parties
uh people to turn out all right
so sorry keep going the wrong way so
just some notation here so uh this is
under this is under the uh name and
reuben model for those who know it you
don't need to know it for the purpose of
this talk
uh you have individual uh treatment
effects so y sub i one is the outcome of
individual i under treatment y sub i
zero is the outcome individual i under
control
uh and you have d sub i which is the
treatment affected by individual now the
key problem is going back to name in 23
you only observe one of these two
because either i i encourage someone to
get out the vote or i don't i give
someone a vaccine or i don't so this d
sub i is a theoretical quantity that i
don't directly observe
right so when there's an estimator d
survive just denote that
sub i but i'm never going to directly
observe that
so back when data was small and we
didn't have that many covariates
everyone was pretty happy because it's
about the only thing you could estimate
what was the average treatment effect
which is the difference of these two the
mean difference between these two and
because the linearity of the
expectations operator this just becomes
an easy problem
right and this is also then calls for
why semi-parametric theory was a pretty
natural fit for causal inference in this
case and sensible this part is
parametric
right because the linearity expectations
operator but in case where you don't
have a randomized experiment or if you
do and you're worried about this finite
sample properties you're going to get a
nuisance parameter which is going to be
in general non-parametric which is going
to be the covariates that have a
relationship with your treatment
assignment and also the outcome and if
it's not randomized you need to control
from
for them uh in order to not get bias
even if it's randomized you wish to
control for them to reduce
uh your variance
so that's the naturalness of the uh
uh theory in the usual case now it's not
so natural because now what we're
interested in is this conditional
average uh treatment effect which says
oh i want to know not what the average
treatment effect is overall but i know
what the average treatment effect is for
substrata of x right conditioning on on
x the way i've written it you know if
you had enough data and your parameters
were small enough p was small enough you
could just like chop it up uh into
subgroups and that's exactly the run
after you get a hydrogen instrument
effect estimate that you claim using
complicated things which we'll get to
the way you would validate it is exactly
do a standard randomized trial for that
substrata of x and see if you could
actually
uh match it
uh but in general this expect this
function here is is is not so easy to
estimate
um you know you need smoothness and
whatnot and it's it gets quite tricky
right
so
in our paper with peter what we did is
we'll say all right we want to estimate
this conditional average treatment
effect there's many ways you could
estimate it you could use a neural net
you could use random forests you could
use os you could do many many things as
many different things people have but
let's create
metal learners these things that your
individual learner your individual
learner can be a random force it could
be a bayesian regression tree it could
be a linear regression
it's gonna it's gonna take those and
it's gonna target this conditional
average tree and effect so you're to
break this down to self-regression
problems
right and it's and it's going to use
some other estimator to solve the sub
progression problems uh it's going to
use the space learners the thing that
this talk and the thing that this
evolved to is well those base owners
themselves
are going to have some bias
a random force is very commonly used
here and it's going to have some bias
and if you don't fix that bias you get
this very serious issue in policy
planning and also then in um confidence
interval estimation if you were worried
about that
right so the reason this thing breaks it
up easily is again because the linearity
of expectations operator it's like all
right we want to estimate this which is
your the treatment effect initial on x
i can break this up into two regression
problems i want to i want to
i want to know what's going to happen
to your outcomes under treated given x
and your outcomes under control given x
which then leads to the most simple meta
learner which is the oldest
thing in the literature goes back to at
least the 1950s one imagines earlier
which is say i'm going to split the data
into two control and treatment groups
and i'm going to estimate separate
response functions for both whatever
learner you wish
right i'm going to estimate mu 1 your
learner on the treated who's denoting
treated mu 0 your learner under control
uh and then you just predict through
both
uh to get your estimate of the
conditional average treatment effect at
x
the obvious thing to note about this is
uh yes you can do this but if the
underlying functions are hard to
estimate as they currently are since we
have a big p
right if the expectation of say your
outcomes under control given x is very
rough
lots of parameters in it uh it's hard to
estimate but your conditional average
treatment effect the difference between
the two is very easy to estimate you've
got yourself into a hard problem and
it's often the difference the
conditional instrument effect itself is
very is much easier to estimate than the
base regression problems uh because as i
i wrote one paper did some theory on
from data from one large tech platform
over a thousand thousands of their
experiments the modal treatment effect
is zero most treatment most treatments
we do have no effect
it's just a zero which is a constant
treatment effect so the k has a
simplification that the underlying
regression functions don't and this
thing is not exploiting that so it's not
going to have a good minimax rate
another thing you can do these the only
two i'm going to talk about in this talk
and i'm going to talk about the one that
peter and us propose because it's not
really
germaine and core what i want to get
across here
is the s learner which is just i'm going
to run a single model
is i'm going to just treat treatment
like any other covariate i'm just going
to treat it like any other covariate i'm
going to run my regression model however
that is could be a lasso it could be
neural net it could be random forest do
whatever you wish
and then at the end i'm just going to
predict through setting treatment to one
honor zero now when your treatment
effect is zero
this may be a better idea than this t
learner because it's not going to spend
its time splitting on
the treatment indicator when that wasn't
great this deal is not going to
necessarily be a fantastic idea because
again it's going to be sitting there
estimating this very difficult estimate
response function if this were to be
difficult to estimate
with these are two base learners the
problems going to talk about occur with
this excellent that we worked on which
is in the case of one of your groups
usually control is way way larger than
the other which is what happens with
online experiments
uh there's also w robust estimators
um and they all have the same problem
with this bias because the bias is
coming from the base learner
right so the most common a very common
used baseliners random forests um and it
we have theory we have results of
asymptotic normality from
uh voger and athey and some previous
work
um i'll talk about that in a little bit
and then people can go off and create
confidence rules those intervals just
have very bad coverage
uh in finite samples and by finite
samples i mean you have hundreds of
thousands of observations
and p could be like 100 and they have
terrible coverage
even when you have millions of
observations appease a hundred they
sometimes don't have the greatest
coverage
but it gets better
but as a prediction algorithm it shows
very good performance in the russian
case particularly when signal to noise
is not very good
uh you can trust applied people they use
it pretty well because there's not that
many hyper parameters to tune in it uh
and it handles sparsity and everything
pretty well
one of the issues is
bryman himself knew
that one of the key tricks for the
random forest thing for it to work quite
well in prediction problems is he's
introduced some bias
and he introduced bias by sub-sampling
the splitting features the m tri thing
in the algorithm right because you're
bagging the trees and then you're also
at every point you're sub selecting the
covariates you have
right and that's going to decorate the
trees across bags that's what's giving
the advantage of bagging if i keep
finding each tree in each bag i'm not
going to gain anything from bagging i
need to introduce some randomness across
bags but i'm also going to do some bias
because i'm not allowing it every split
point for me to examine all the
covariates and you can imagine saying i
have a hundred kaverites only five of
them matter
um but those five are only going to show
up sometimes and i'm going to induce
this uh bias that occurs brian knew
about this she wrote about it even tried
to do a bias adjustment that mostly has
been forgotten in the literature
it's very easy to show it's trivial to
show that random force have this bias in
this simple case
there's 10 covariates it's linear model
is deemed to be true
only three of them matter you fit a
random forest the truth is on the 45
degree line you get you get this biased
estimate
um and it's and it's very
straightforward to show our very simple
theory that we all talk about at the end
it deals with this simple case of this
linear case
right so that's the bias you want to get
you get rid of it's
the literature kind of forgot about it
but brian knew about it he tried to have
a fix about it his fix that is his own
issues
um
right so this previous work in trying to
fix this bias uh breiman's work itself i
think could best be understood i think
peter and peter was not alone other
people told me as well that leo
uh had thought that random force can't
overfit
um someone else told me at one time
people thought adaboos couldn't overfit
either uh i guess that's always the way
it works uh renforce more certainly can
overfit and his and his attempt to bias
adjustment turns into a boosting thing
that you run around a forest and then
you keep running it over and over again
on the residuals uh using all the
covariates um and and and you stop at
some point holding using a holdout set
um its performance can get
now you get this problem of you can very
easily
over fit you could you make predictions
outside the range of y because of the
boosting component and now you're kind
of in the soup of i got hyper parameters
once i have hyper parameters why am i
not just doing xgb boost why am i not
doing
uh neural nets because because those are
noun
once i once i've bought bit the bullet
and say that i have these hyper
parameters i have to tune carefully then
why don't i just use machinery
that and estimators that are built
around that uh there's been other
attempts as well
um
none of them quite work well
without hyper parameter tuning which is
what you're trying to avoid in these
pipelines uh because if you're trying to
avoid him i'm not going to do random
force i'm going to switch to xg booster
or something else that's a little more
complicated that does very well in these
prediction problems
if you go to kaggle random force gets
beat by xg boost quite handily although
random force is quite competitive
so we i'll tell you our algorithm i'm
going to give you some simulations give
you a good example i'm going to show you
some very simple theory
and and our algorithm is very simple and
it's simple
consciously because you need something
that you could deploy in pipelines
that will have a some semblance of do no
harm right so it's not like you have to
make sure that the analyst is getting
very acute about hyper parameters
because i'll guarantee you the analysts
will not get treated about hyper
parameters because that's just not what
happens
uh in practice
right so what we do is we just run the
forest and then we just regress y
on the predictions of the forest you
don't let the forest see its own
covariates again and it's not boosting
you just run y and y hat again using the
forest
right and at the last step you do a
regression adjustment with just
uh two covariates which is the intercept
and y hat
that last thing at the end
ends up being important if you don't do
the ols thing at the end the force can
continuously regularize actually
it could be that as i go through these
rounds the regularization
problem gets worse not better
the other thing we do and i'm just going
to parenthetically highlight this
is that theory for rental force is very
hard to do so what people did is in
order to get the asymptotic normality
results they kind of like
worked very hard to ignore that you run
a random force
and one way to do it is you could have
done what leo did and just do like out
of bag
which just made a lot of sense but what
they did instead is did this honest
random forest and what the honest random
forest is is i i sample my data now
whether it's by bootstrap or i take a
half sample doesn't matter and then what
i do is i split my data again in half
now it doesn't have to be half it could
be some other proportion but it doesn't
matter
and on the first half the data i grow my
i grow my forest using the usual rules
then i delete all my outcome data and
then from the other half of the data i
drop it through my tree
and that's feed into my terminal nodes
and that's my outcome data and in this
way i've made my tree structure
conditionally independent of my outcome
and now i can like for the purpose of
theory mostly ignore that i've done
random forests right now i just got some
boxes i independently got the boxes and
now i'm off the races under regularity
assumptions to go prove asymptotic
normality that's the way theory works
it's great and the theory um relies on
sub sampling
and which is also great which is peter's
on work on and the reason i need sub
sampling is because when i split my data
into the splitting set in the averaging
set i got and then i'm going to predict
through i got to make sure that when i'm
predicting through the observation
predicting through isn't sitting there
in my averaging set because if it is
i got a problem again i break the
independence so the theory gets around
it by sub sampling
all of the software that uses this just
sets the sampling rate of 0.5
as a ratio i know what 0.5 is it ain't
subsampling it doesn't say square root
of n because no user would ever use that
because it gives terrible performance so
if it's a classic case the theory is
correct theory does what it does and it
ends up in an algorithm
that
that by its very default design by the
same authors will violate the theory so
you don't actually so what you end up
getting is unlike if you just roll back
to
uh leo's original code it wouldn't have
this problem this other code has the
following problem i randomly generate y
unit very normal i readily generate x
universally
you know variant normal i regress y and
x using the force and go what's the
correlation between y hat
and y
it's going to claim a correlation of
over 2 over 20
why because it's not subsampling like
the theory required this definition of
honesty had that y sitting in the
averaging set and you got and you got
yourself a problem so instead of relying
on sub sampling we change the algorithm
more inspired by
by what leo would i think do
uh but still get this honesty principle
by just doing an out-of-bag kind of
honesty i won't get into it but you're
doing you're just guaranteeing by
algorithmic design so when i'm
predicting observation i it cannot be
sitting in either the data set it
constructed the tree nor the data set
that i got the averaging data from all
right this is an example that we write
theories one way it looks fine
and then three steps on you're like well
what are you going to actually do in the
code you're actually not going to do
sub-something for this problem because
the
the performance as a predictor would be
quite bad
even though you needed it theoretically
for the confidence intervals so that's
not actually what's done
right so we don't include so that's one
thing we don't include any covariates um
because we want to do the stability
because we don't complete the game we
want to avoid the tuning thing because
we don't that's not stable in the
pipelines and if it were stable i'm not
going to do random force anyways i want
to do something else
right and the last thing is you want uh
leave one out a less
at the last step uh to get the because
regularization is going to get you on
the wrong scale
so if you did all that and this is an
algorithmic form it's very simple
uh then it's just what i said uh in this
case it fixes the bias now this case of
course
trivial for it um as we'll see from our
theory our very simple theory that as i
told you the true here is a linear model
there's ten covariates uh only a three
matter any sub-sampling is going to
induce a bias and we can theoretically
show that a linear adjustment at the end
is going to get you uh get you back
uh is going to correct uh the bias thing
so that's the thing that's the idea
that's how he got into this and no one
of the ways we got into this problem was
ignoring leo who actually did
applications that oh yeah his forests
were biased
uh we also moved away from out of bag to
this honesty thing that seemed clever
and it is clever but actually got us
into a bigger problem than just undoing
it so part of the joke about this has
been is on two different layers i'm
doing
uh 20 years statistical development back
to you know
uh and you're like uh i know i'll leave
there might have been a gain if i had
stopped reading
um
anyways so
so uh so here
these are empirical kate simulations
these simulations are not ours it's from
uh from this wonderful paper by leewa
emanuel
um and in there they report that if you
do
uh conformal interval and of course very
good uh properties if you use uh any of
these standard learners
um it empirical coverage is 70 to 90 so
it's not very good uh we don't change
the simulations at all we just devised
it in this very simple way and we'll see
is like in the high dimensional cases
where the problem arose that uh coverage
is now much closer to nominal
obviously it's not perfect you can see
it's undercovering a tiny bit
uh here and here conformal of course is
uh provides uh guaranteed coverage and
it's and it's very good but it does fix
this map this quite large
bias i'll give you some of our own
simulations where it doesn't look as
good i created some adversarial
simulations
in a second
um
so the thing is the the intervals are
much much smaller so the coverage is not
quite as good as conformal it's very
good the intervals are much much smaller
the conformal intervals are so large
that as i said in data problems you can
have an average human effect or t-stat
of three and conformal
thinks that nothing is significant um
and and i know what users are going to
do they're just going to like go do some
random thing now uh they're not going to
stop at this point and you know you
would like him to think well maybe an
engine's human effect or trying to
estimate more complicated model maybe i
should just revert back to the uh to the
mean estimate you get a selective
inference problem but
that's not what's going to happen
uh we'd like it to happen but i'm here
to tell you that's not what 98 of users
are going to do
right
all right so that wasn't the main
motivation
one more simulation there's an
adversarial submission it's the same
simulation from this paper with uh peter
it comes from the science paper article
that two of my grad students wrote david
brockman and josh kala in which uh they
uh they showed a policy and an
intervention that would reduce
transphobia
um it got a lot of media attention not
only because it was about transphobia
but also because there was a
pre-existing article on the topic that
turned to be fraudulent that david and
josh found through data forensic was
utterly fraudulent but data was
completely made up
uh it's a pretty extreme case of being
fraudulent the vegito was made up but
the intervention itself which was done
by a third party was actually good so
they thought they needed to do it uh now
part of what happened is that using
experimental design that uh that i david
and josh came up with which was to have
a lot of power and the way that small
design gets a lot of power is it
collects covariates they're very
powerful predictors of outcomes
right so what ends up happening is
although in their experiment the
t-statistic the average human effect is
well over three
the
the treatment is less correlated with
your outcomes than your baseline
covariance that we gathered we did that
because that's going to give you lots of
power when you adjust for it and we
adjust for it in front of design so the
r squared of enviro grass y on your
baseline covariates is like point a so
that's like having five times the sample
if you just do the algebra for that so
if you throw that though with the s
learner the s learns up being horribly
biased because whether you do lasso or
you do ridge or you do random forest
because the regularization is making you
regularize the treatment effect very
seriously
um see the simulations based on that
real data this is the signal to noise
ratio set to what it was in the data
this is with higher is for lower and you
could see yes
we picked the learner which is
particularly bad the coverage in this
data simulation is very bad it's way
worse than in liwon and danielle's uh
uh simulations it's like less than 20
when you ask for 95 interval if you do
the bias correction still not great um
it's because you're not it's still not
overcoming the central problem
that the s learner is not targeting the
causal effect so there's probably a
different learner you should use the one
that pure and i and our co-op has
proposed us better here but you know it
still makes it's moving in the right
direction or very large since as an
applied person i'll tell you if i could
get 75
coverage of when i asked for 95 for a
problem i actually care about this is a
massive win let me put this way if i
again if we go hey on the mra vaccine
should we have a fourth booster or fifth
booster our biggest we have nowhere near
75 percent coverage of our uh uh of our
uh our predictions so all of the game is
how biased our estimates because they're
very biased
um so from a fiscal sense this is bad
from a policy sense amen and most
problems i work on i'd be happy to take
this and i don't get this because i'm
worried about the bias side
um
so the applied example here is
uh is the skeletal vote campaign uh
we've done it on lots of different vote
campaigns done it on medical things
you've done it on
uh uh some finance examples uh this one
is that all right so we did this in this
paper got a lot of feedback on this
paper and people have literally
found out users apply people found out
this bias so in the united states
whether you vote or not is a matter of
public record for whom you vote is
private but whether you vote or not is
public record that kind of creeps people
out so a very effective treatment is
this very simple mailer
in which you send out a mailer and they
say hey what if your neighbors knew
whether you voted or not and and you you
tell people the voting history of
themselves and their neighbors and they
tell telling that after the election
you're going to mail out an updated
version of this
um
and and then it gets people to turn out
the vote it causes an increase of voting
about say seven percent
uh kind of varies on is it on your off
year exactly but that's a massive
treatment effect for for a postcard
which is very cheap now some people do
seem to have a negative treatment effect
and other people have no effect at all
so there is a backlash so you do want to
target it
right
so so in our paper what we showed was
and this is just from our paper that is
the condition though there's a histogram
traditional average shrewing effect
across individuals and it's a
large-scale
study this in our paper this was a 120
000 controls about thirty thousand
treated
uh that's been replicated in studies
with millions of observations well you
see the same thing there's a large human
effect yes the average human effect is
quite large uh one is coded whether you
vote zero code if you're not um and
these shaded error your arias are
confidence intervals for whether it's
significant and what proportion those
bins significantly departs from zero you
can see that yes there's a large average
human effect but there is a subgroup for
which there is actually evidence you
want to target that
uh it varies a lot by
age or your prior probability of voting
this is the x axis here is your prior
probability of voting the treatment
effect is pretty intuitive is quite
large if you have some history of voting
but you don't always vote if you always
vote is much less if you never vote
uh it's much less here's the box plots i
think are the easiest way to see that if
you don't have a voting history at all
it might have a zero treatment effect
which i think makes sense if you never
vote it's kind of hard to get you to
vote
um
right so in this case so you can do it
by simulation and then on the actual
data so we take the same simulations
from a previous paper
and data inspired so you like just
assume
uh that the data and the response model
is true
that the d bias estimates
then give you an average treatment
effect estimate of two percent where the
truth is one point eight percent
and if you don't devise them like we
didn't in that paper
uh and then people when they implemented
this and their pipelines didn't devise
it you get a pretty biased estimate of
one percent so you're pretty far off
um and so you're off on the mean and
you're especially harming uh predictions
away from the mean
um
and also you gain mean squared error not
on your prediction of why
but on your prediction of the kate
itself obviously you're not getting mean
squared in the official or why because
the
base learner force did that mean
variance trade off correctly as it was
uh designed to do
so on the policy side if you go through
this you're like okay uh you know votes
are going to be worth different amounts
to different actors different campaigns
um and in different settings uh but if
you say that okay votes are worth say
thirty one dollars that corresponds to a
conditional treatment effect of two
percent
um so i'm gonna increase probably voting
by two percent the device estimates
imply that well i should target almost
half of my potential voters
um the
the un
devised thing was only 32 percent and
the true percent is in the simulation so
if you know it's true it's 45 percent
if the vote is worth much less and this
is what it's kind of like for
mayor mayoral elections and whatnot they
need a conditional average human effect
uh five percent
uh and now it says you should target
about seven percent of potential voters
rather than three percent the truth is
8.4
and then the device predictions also are
fixing this negative thing at the bottom
end
um the device things think that 12
potential voters have a negative effect
from this mailer of the de-bias thing
had almost 30 percent and the true
percentage is like uh 18 in the
simulation the same thing parallels on
real data
um we have
medical examples and others all right
i'm going the wrong way i keep doing
that all right so very simple theory so
the very simple theory is all right uh
much like for random neural nets for
metaphors people worked up simple linear
models uh as a way to understand random
forest because doing theater and
rainforest is very hard so imagine the
data is generated by uh a linear model
iid
um and then and then here's the key
thing i'm gonna bag it and the key thing
is i want to go up and estimate those
coefficients i'm going to i'm going to
substitute a random subset of the linear
uh co
features in each bag so i'm going to bag
a linear model i'm going to subset
covariates
in each bag and then i'm going to
average over bags
right so when the size the subset is
smaller than the original parameters
uh and i get a lot enough i get enough
bags uh this estimator then is going to
give you a scaled version of the ols
estimators and then uh estimates and
then
probably pretty obviously given the
setup a single linear step bias
correction can devise the pointwise
predictions of the estimator
right so you assume that this is uh the
low dimensional case which probably
worked out the high dimensional case so
n is greater than d d is the number of
features here uh you assume the data is
being deviated uh we subset
uh
less than the number of covariates and
then what you're going to get is as you
start bagging your
your your actual less coefficients are
scaled version of the true coefficients
uh here
um
and again given the setup it's pretty
obvious i think then oh well if i do a
one-step linear
fix which is i don't i don't use the
covariance i just go y and y-hat i get a
scale parameter if i go estimate i get a
scale mean and variance i go do that i'm
going to be i'm going to be then fine
right so what you can learn from the
very simple theoretical example is that
well consistency in the point wise bias
because power to estimate and correct
the bias this is not always possible
because you're going to have small data
and heterogeneous point wise bias and
that's going to make it kind of
unfeasible
um so i'm running out of time i'm going
to say that okay so bias prediction can
help fix these random forces i've
noticed the same thing with their own
that's saying notice the same thing with
xgboos although not as
drastic
partly the key things is for things like
xg boost
and neural nets they're they're tuned
for the prediction problem which makes a
certain um mean variance
a bias variance trade-off not the policy
uh bias variance trade-off that you want
to make
um and although it's not the main
motivation i think it's like helpful for
confidence intervals before this work we
kept thinking well you know
you get estimators whose bias is going
down root n
you you want confidence intervals that
root in of course the bias is going to
be really bad you can't make progress
because you're not getting the
parametric rate turned out i don't think
that's what's going on i i'm sure that's
what's going on part two but you have a
simple problem
thank my co-authors and we have software
we have lots of software go check
software and i shall stop
well thank you jess for wonderful uh i
mean presentation it was so wonderful
you alone forget to uh to turn on uh
so it's great uh thanks to peter too i
think it's a special treatment for a
special day so a long didn't test today
so let me see
if there are any questions
but we need to give picture the
microphone
jazz i was just wondering with these
very complicated situations
uh
can you sort of measure the effect on
your bias
of um
you know factors confounding factors
which you don't know and don't observe
or you have in other words can you get
some idea of what magnitude of
perturbation
uh
could
uh
really ruin these these these
predictions
yeah that's a great point it's um
now there's you can't get something for
nothing as
our friend david friedman once said put
a pull a rabbit out of a hat you're
going to put the rabbit in the hat first
so in this case uh yes but now you have
to bring some structural knowledge
like in these policy evaluation cases
they're complicated the upside is people
have structural knowledge because they
keep doing it or at least they claim to
uh at least gonna have a conversation
about it and now you're like yes okay so
these are the perturbations that are
important this is i think the size of
those perturbations
and that's a long process
right it's sort of like it's like it's
it's you know i was trying to bend the
other day it's like hey man like you
know for statistics we've been doing it
for over 100 years we've agreed on two
numbers
your estimate and your variance surely
we should have another number that's
something about stability
a perturbation like you're saying like
what's the bias that could be threat
what's the third number and we haven't
agreed on a third number and i think
part of why we haven't agreed on third
number
is it's very contingent on your problem
at hand
like maybe for your problem your p-value
is not relevant as i'm arguing it often
isn't but at least everyone knows crank
the machine out comes this p-value which
is the kind of perturbation
right so the per division over the
randomization distribution the case for
a randomized control trial or the
sampling distribution kind of sampling
so in practice i do those perturbations
a lot
those depend crucially
on the application and then how bad we
think the bias is i mean an example i'll
give which is like hey man if you know
you know you're all going to retire you
all have some investments if you think
the equity markets the next five years
have done what they've done in the last
five years that's probably unwise
because we haven't had inflation since
the 1970s and we now do right so
everyone every macro conference in a
room can think this through and we know
like when you look at the data what
how the data is biased for the near
future
and we can have a conversation now if
you're not with a room full of
macroeconomists that's that's not an
easy conversation now like all the
macros will not they'll still disagree
about the magnitude when will revert
when it will not avert but it's that's
like the
that covered shift that's occurred
is it can be reasoned through so if
anyone in that case is going to have
some data one's going to then say all
right how do we think that through um
and of course people disagree on that
that's kind of what happened between the
fda and the israelis
um was you're getting old people that
were getting an extra backs the people
in the fda were like well what about the
bias and then the israeli which i agreed
with was like yes these are old sick
people so the bias goes the wrong way
who's getting the booster or people at
risk not the people not at risk
so you think the bias has a different
sign and i go that makes sense to me and
some people the fd goes oh no it's
biased and i don't want to give you the
sign and i'm like well you have a
decision to make you better sign this
and i think the sign direction the
israeli epidemic you're making was the
correct one but now you get this
it's not unresolvable i think we
eventually made the right decision
partly because we did that perturbation
you're asking i was like okay there's a
thing we can't observe it what how do
which direction do we think is the sign
behaviorally
and it was it would be pretty
unreasonable to think it's the other way
that old people are getting it less and
they were at less risk that makes no
sense
so let me see uh yeah so sorry
thank you very much for the excellent
talk i felt i learned a lot
i have two questions the first is about
your theory about the what um
random forest does um
i thought i i want to reconcile this
with something else i've read there was
a paper from people at rice university
saying that when you go through the
bagging you get something that looks
like a ridge estimator
and it's by geneva allen and colleagues
which is not what you get you get a
rescale version of ols you don't get the
ridge estimator so
so maybe can you please clarify for me
the difference between the two why is it
that you're not getting the ridge and
you're getting a rescale to ls
yeah so uh
it is you're here let me let me see if i
have the slides uh i can send you notes
uh after on it our results are
consistent with theirs and this other
channel art thing here let me see if i
i'm not sure i have these notes here
um
there is
there is uh i don't i don't have it i
don't have it here but i i know those
results our results are not inconsistent
with them but i don't have the results
here to give you a clear answer i think
but in the
are did they have like the p less than n
case
yeah i think so
yeah i i i can't off the top of my head
but i've seen those i have those results
we'll i'll see i'll send you the notes
thank you but i don't know off the top
of my head and my second question is
more of an observation is about of
course the con the comparison with
conformal prediction so the goals are
very different i think
oh wait i do know the results sorry
sorry i'm sorry i'll go back to the may
i answer the previous result the
question yes so the theory i gave here
was a linear model not ols this is all
less i'm subsetting ols
um i'm bagging all s i'm subsetting the
oles
and then you get the bag result i think
this is the same setting as what they
have if i remember correctly
all right we should we should talk about
it okay
the second is about the conformal
prediction it's more like a
clarification conformal is really trying
to predict the individual treatment
effect itself not its mean
and so the fact that conformal
predictive intervals are wider is a
necessity because
you're not
you're trying to
to predict a random variable not a
parameter
so if i can speak that way and so the
fact that they're wider
and i think there's room for both right
there's both there are cases where you
really want to know the mean in cases
where you might actually care about the
variability around the mean
because
and i think judea pearl
argues about this a whole lot which is
that you know if the mean is positive
but for a lot of people they actually
have negative effects you know that you
would want to know about this
and so it's just a perhaps a
clarification that because one method is
is designed
to predict an outcome a random outcome
then that's by necessity
the
the prediction interval will typically
be much wider
uh i i agree
although
the simulations i showed for
on
on
comparing it to conformal we're doing it
on the individual effect
you're basically you're estimating the k
you're using the k to estimate the
individual effect and you're comparing
it on the individual effect
and this and the coverage
properties of it are on off the
individual effect
on y one minus y zero
yeah under same simulation as yours just
same everything's the same
right so maybe we can talk about this
offline because there are many the
conformal is not a really a method it's
like what base learner you're using and
things like that but maybe i'll i'll
follow up uh
yeah
thank you
christian
okay i have a
well maybe a related question to that so
there seem to be some some of my social
science friends tell me that if you do
these shaming experiments there's really
a large difference on whether you are
more democrat or republican leading so
it seems to work much better on
democrats
whereas a republican lenient will say
screw you i don't i don't want to be
changed into anything i do what i want
to do
and
now would that have an effect on so when
you d bias
could it be that in this example you
would debias amine but you actually make
the effect of these two heterogeneous
groups worse
yeah that's a great question so um
one it could always be
uh that you do make it worse
in the shaming thing for voting there's
not a partisan effect
because the norm of voting is not
partisan uh the shaming effects show up
in pretty partisan cases like for
example a famous one is in los angeles
uh the power company when he was trying
to shame people to conserve energy
and it had a differential effect among
republicans and democrats republicans
started consuming more energy because
because unfortunately when it comes to
energy
uh and environmental issues it's become
the norm is not
it's become partisanly aligned
uh the voting norm does not itself have
a partisan divide so we don't see it in
this case but in those cases we do see
it
um i am sure
i am certain there will be cases that if
you de-bias it it's going to like induce
a problem
right i haven't seen it but doesn't mean
it won't occur i'm sure it will occur
bad things will always occur in data
um and it's certainly true that there
are part
shaming in general if you use norms that
are um have a partisan cleavage on them
will play out in partisanly divided ways
would you rather not be biased if you
know that there's a partisan
effect well if well if the if the if the
buyer if the if the biased staff is
causing like i don't know if it is i'm
willing to believe
like anything someone says i i have an x
machine
can it cause a problem x will always
cause a problem in some settings i don't
know whether the d biasing will will
cause an issue
here uh in in that case
um i'm just saying it might i don't know
what i am observing is what the d bias
is partly doing is mostly happening in
the tails
is the force is regularizing the tails
um quite a lot
right so when the force tails come in
um
so it's actually
you can
because the slides that i had is that
and and in the non-linear versions of it
that's where it's helping
uh not in the mean so much so the device
is a bigger issue on the tail so it's
like hey if it's tail behavior it's
going to have the devising's a bigger
deal on the tails
right you should think of you're just
thinking about what a force does at the
end right it's like i'm in a
neighborhood
i'm using a mean estimator
i'm going to get neighborhoods in the
mean at the end i'm doing a shrinkage
towards the mean of the last node so the
tail the devicing steps actually help
the tails more than anything else
so if the bias is happening the tails
then i think the devising may help
but
but i imagine i'm sure this case is
really hard
yeah so uh yeah i mean we are running a
bit late uh less thanks to jazz again
and this concludes
right